so we have the question Devon is going
to make three shelves for her father she
has a piece of lumber that is 12 feet
long she wants the top shelf to be half
a foot shorter than the middle shelf so
let me do this in different colors she
wants the top shelf the top shelf to be
half a foot shorter than the middle
shelf
so I'll just let's just read the whole
thing first and the bottom shelf to be
half a foot shorter than twice the
length of the top shelf let me do that
in a different color then blue the
bottom the bottom shelf to be half a
foot shorter then twice the length of
the top shelf
how long will each shelf be if she uses
the entire 12 feet of wood so let's
define some variables for our different
shelves because that's what we have to
figure out we have the top shelf the
middle shelf and the bottom shelf so
let's say that T is equal to length of
top shelf T for top of top shelf let's
make em let's make em equal the length
the length of the middle shelf the
middle shelf M for middle and then let's
make B let's make B equal to the length
of the bottom shelf B for bottom bottom
shelf so let's see what these different
statements tell us so this first
statement she says she wants the top
shelf and I'll do it in that same color
she wants the top shelf to be half a
foot shorter than the middle cell so she
wants the length of the top shelf the
top shelf to be so this is equal to half
a foot shorter than the middle shelf
middle shelf so if we're doing
everything in feet it's going to be the
middle the length of the middle shelf
and feet minus 1/2 minus 1/2 feet so
that's what that sentence in orange is
telling us the top shelf needs to be
half a foot shorter than the length of
the middle shelf now what's the next
date
tell us and the bottom shelf to be so
the bottom shelf needs to be equal to
half a foot shorter then so it's half a
foot shorter half a foot shorter then
twice the length of the top shelf so
it's half a foot shorter then twice the
length of the top shelf so these are the
two the these are the two statements
interpreted an equal equation form the
top shelfs length has to be equal to the
middle shelf length minus 1/2 it's 1/2
foot shorter than the middle shelf and
then the bottom shelf needs to be half a
foot shorter then twice the length of
the top shelf and so how do we solve
this well you can't just solve it just
with these two constraints but she could
they give us more information they tell
us they tell us how long will each shelf
be if she uses the entire 12 feet of
wood so the lengths of all of the
shelves have to add up to 12 feet she's
using all of them so T plus M plus B
needs to be equal to 12 feet that's the
lengths of each of them she's using all
of all 12 feet of the woods so the
lengths have to add to 12 so what can we
do here well we can get everything here
in terms of one variable maybe we'll do
it in terms of M and then substitute so
we already have T in terms of M we
already have T in terms of M we could
everywhere where we see a T we can
substitute with M minus 1/2 but here we
have B in terms of T so how can we put
this in terms of M well we know that T
is equal to M minus 1/2 so let's take
everywhere we see a t let's substitute
it with this thing right here that is
what T is equal to so we can rewrite
this blue equation as the length of the
bottom shelf is 2 times the length of
the top shelf T but we know that T is
equal to M minus 1/2 so M minus 1/2
minus 1/2 minus 1/2 and if we wanted to
simplify that a little bit this would be
that the bottom shelf the bottom shelf
is equal to let's distribute the 2 2
times M is 2 M
two times negative 1/2 is negative 1 and
then minus another 1/2 or we could
rewrite this as B is equal to 2 times
the middle shelf minus 3 halves right
1/2 is 2 halves minus another half is
negative or 3 halves just like that so
now we have everything in terms of M and
we can substitute back here so the top
shelf the top shelf instead of putting a
T there we could put M minus 1/2 so we
put M minus 1/2 plus the length of the
middle shelf plus the length of the
middle shelf plus the length of the
bottom shelf well we already put that in
terms of M that's what we just did this
is the length of the bottom shelf in
terms of M so instead of writing B there
we could write 2m minus three-halves
plus 2m minus three-halves and that is
equal to 12 all we did is substitute for
T we wrote T in terms of M and we wrote
B in terms of M now let's combine the M
terms and the constant terms so if we
have we have one M here we have another
M there and then we have a 2m there
they're all positive so 1 plus 1 plus 2
is 4 M so we have 4 m and then what are
our constant terms tell us we have a
negative 1/2 and then we have a negative
three-halves so negative 1/2 minus
three-halves that is negative 4 halves
or negative 2 so we have 4 M minus 2 and
of course we still have that equals 12
now we want to isolate just the M
variable on one side of the equation so
let's add 2 to both sides to get rid of
this 2 on the left-hand side so if we
add 2 to both sides of this equation the
left-hand side we're just left with 4 M
these guys cancel out is equal to is
equal to 14 now divide both sides by 4
divide both sides by 4 we get M is equal
to 14 over 4 or we could call that 7
halves
seven-halves feet because we're doing
everything in feet so we've solved for
EM but now we still have to solve for T
and B so let's do that let's solve for T
T is equal to M minus 1/2 so it's equal
to our M is 7 halves minus 1/2 which is
equal to 6 halves or 3 feet everything
is in fees so that's how we know its
feet there so that's the top shelf is 3
feet the middle shelf is 7 halves feet
which is the same thing as three and a
half three and a half feet and then the
bottom shelf is two times the top shelf
minus one half so what's that going to
be equal to that's going to be equal to
two times three feet that's what the
length of the top shelf is minus 1/2
which is equal to 6 minus 1/2 or five
and a half feet five and a half feet and
we're done and you can verify that these
definitely do add up to 12 five and a
half plus three and a half is 9 plus 3
is 12 feet and it meets all of the other
constraints the top shelf is half a foot
shorter than the middle shelf and the
bottom shelf is half a foot shorter than
two times the top shelf and we are done
we know how many how the lengths of the
shelves that Devon needs to make